ladies and gentlemen who's remain
standing for the oath of office followed
by musical honors
please raise your right hand and repeat
after me
i kamala davey harris do solemnly swear
davey harrison that i will support and
defend
the constitution of the united states
that i will support
and defend the constitution against
all enemies born in domestic against all
enemies that i will bear true
faith and allegiance to the sin that i
will bear true
faith and allegiance to the same that i
take this obligation
freely that i take this obligation
freely without any mental reservation
or purpose of evasion without any mental
reservation
or purpose of evasion that i will well
and faithfully discharge that i will
well
and faithfully discharge the duties of
the office on which i am about to enter
the duties of the office upon which i am
about to enter
so help me god so help me god
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen please be seated